so M this is a sample of rubidium it
arrived it a couple of days ago from our
further company so there's one gram of
rubidium it cost about 65 pounds it's
one of the alkali metals so it's very
very reactive a bit like sodium but
perhaps a little bit more so the metal
itself is quite low melting it won't
melt with my hand though unfortunately
so I'm not going to show you it liquid
now but you can see there's one gram of
the metal inside this glass ampule it's
very reactive and we're going to explore
its chemistry now by by putting this
into some water well we've got this
really neat device which Neel put
together last Friday and you can see
it's it's it's got a hammer which is
going to break the glass so it's near
what does it do so when the hammer Falls
literally will break the glass the
rubidium will just drop into the big
bucket water that we got underneath
rubidium is an alkali metal that comes
between potassium and cesium and both
potassium and cesium are much better
known among chemists than rubidium
potassium because it's all over the
world the environment you have potassium
in cells and plants and so on I mean
biological cells rubidium on the other
hand is quite rare so I'm going to give
the sample net Anil Anil is going to
load it and then we're going to drop the
hammer
they're gonna it was discovered
originally by the German chemist Bunsen
woodenness there he was pulled the one
who invented the Bunsen burner and he
discovered it by looking at the colors
that you see in flames when he was
heating up water that came from mineral
water that came from Springs somewhere
in Germany I believe or it may have been
somewhere in middle Europe so Neil is
arranging the sample of rubidium against
the metallic back plate in a small
metallic Collider rubidium gives the
characteristic current color that is
different from lilac of sodium or I'm
sorry lyla to potassium or the orange of
sodium the rubidium is slightly more
reactive than sodium so when we did the
sodium experiments we had our safety
glasses and coat on
but for rubidium we're gonna wear
secondary goggles so here's my safety
goggles which I'm going to put on top
don't we look good nowadays one of the
main uses of rubidium is actually in
physics rather than chemistry because
you can heat up rubidium metal to a high
temperature and get a vapor of rubidium
atoms in a specially constructed heated
cell and you can get very interesting
effects from shining very intense laser
light into rubidium atoms and the
rubidium atoms can do a whole series of
different very elegant physics
experiments so rubidium has got a life
of its own in physics but in chemistry
it's perhaps slightly neglected
say that two-step
was that it
don't think I needed my safety screen
well it was a very exciting was it in
Dec yeah
so gone you were right it was just a
fizzle